welcome to things
that I would have liked to know
before I went to high school
there are no perse good or bad nelkas
there are only good or bad teachers
Homework is not controlled
but are the bestklausurenvorbereitung
you will get many more grades from the teachers
so best ask early
the 11th grade is much easier
because the teachers also understanding
have for your start problems
takes advantage of the Aus
and does not waste directly
your strike options
does not work with a folder in any case
but best with an iPad or stapler
between 14 and 15 points
are with regard to the oral grade
only 1 subjective difference
goes to celebrate as many as possible at the beginning of high school
to meet all the people
in the exam phase
you will not have time for this
By the way,
many people write to me
that they had wished
To have followed me even before high school
so if you are still in high school now
likes to follow me
I post quite a few school tips